so this was big and this happened this
week also President Obama said that he
won't wait for Congress to push his
legislative agenda through this sort of
goes to what we were just talking about
because we do have separation of powers
and Congress is supposed to make laws
the president supposed to execute them
but that's really not what he's saying
he's going to do here he's going to use
executive orders as much as possible
here's exactly what he said we are not
just going to be waiting for legislation
in order to make sure that we're
providing Americans the kind of help
that they need I've got a pen and I've
got a phone and if I can use that pen to
sign executive orders and take executive
actions and I've got a phone that allows
me to convene Americans from every walk
of life okay that seems slightly
problematic to me again separation of
powers he's supposed to enact the law is
not write them um but he does have some
leeway with this kind of stuff and I'm
not defending Congress they don't do
anything right their approval rates at
seven percent they hate the guy they
don't want to do anything with them uh
but is there a little danger in a
president that saying I'm not gonna wait
for the rest of the system to work and
I'm just gonna go ahead and do it i was
gonna mavericky yet yeah us read the
sounds very Emperor Palpatine from Star
Wars anything so why I like I yes
idealistically I totally agree yes it's
I'm agree of course but that's wrong
because that's like that is the liberal
idea like your ideal is you you kind of
want things to work the way they're
supposed to work and I think that's why
we always lose is because the other side
doesn't really care yeah if things work
that way like I think a big complaint
about President Obama's first term is
that he tried very hard to do things the
right way and they said no every time
exactly and I think when you look at how
Bush and Cheney ran things it was with
kind of an iron fist and I didn't like
those decisions so I really hated the
means that they were gotten but if that
if those are now the rules of the game
Democrats can't get into the White House
lose at every legislative opportunity
for eight years hand it back to the
other side okay you guys destroy the
country and then we'll like do our best
to fix it the right like yeah kind of
have to otherwise the pendulum has to
swing the other way or nothing we're
just gonna keep going down a darker
smaller government's less protection
path right but he's in there a risk in
the pendulum swinging the other way and
then you know let's say a Republican
gets in that you don't agree with his
agenda and then he says we'll screw you
Congress because Obama set the president
I'm gonna do everything by executive
order so how do we how do we negotiate
how they should all work because you
can't like it if it's your guy and
they're not like if the other guy right
that's the principal thing you were
talking about so I'm talking about is
that I i think obama hasn't set the
president I think this president had
been set by the previous administration
and actually Obama though you has used a
lot of executive orders they're not has
not used them in quite as sweeping ways
as Bush has and I think this goes to a
bigger issue with the Democratic Party
being so bad at being Congress yeah
being in Congress even when they had the
majority and even as minority there
they're just terrible at uniting behind
a thing like they don't they all because
it's all like oh no the idealistic thing
that nobody wants to compromise in with
each other in the demo compromise with
the Republicans eff yeah but we got a
budget this week exactly but it's it's
Democrats are really bad at coming
together and making things happen
Republicans are really good at it and so
whatever way Democrats can move their
agenda for it seems like it's going to
be good because the agenda is going to
be coming back the other way next time
around so he's part of this problem
besides this sort of the specific things
that you're talking about that we sort
of forget what is supposed to govern us
like I've now said the separation power
is ten times but like that we don't
really spend any time really realizing
that we have a branch that decides
what's legal a branch is supposed to
pass laws and a branch that's supposed
to execute the laws and because so it
really comes to me this has comes down
to education like if people really
understood how the system supposed to
work maybe we wouldn't have to deal with
a lot of the nonsense that Jack's
talking about right this is just an
education thing no it's a great point
and I think that people you know I think
you know the Affordable Care Act has
been like a really amazing you know
offering of Obama's campaign but I think
in general a lot of people wish that he
would have been able to accomplish more
and so I think six years in to say
something like this I think
i don't know i think it's a it's a
positive i don't know if it's a positive
thing necessarily but i think that
people kind of want to hear that from
him right and also he doesn't have to
run for reelection so at this point
maybe he's just putting the pedal to
metal and being like screw you guys i'm
gonna do whatever the hell i can get
away with what I think you're I think
you're right there I think that's
actually the problem with with the whole
situation is if more congressman didn't
worry about re-election if there were
term limits that you know could make it
that you know we had a lot of
congressmen who were who were doing it
for two terms and then getting out or
three terms and getting out then I think
you could see more movement in a good
way but everybody so worried about
protecting their seats that just
nothing's going to get done it's a
balance between idealism and
practicality and the fact is like I want
the idealistic version to work but then
we have to fix the system and like give
and sent it like the incentives are
aligned with our best interests yeah and
I'm an idealist which is why I'm doing
this instead of I guess running for
Congress or something like that